blue yeti tu pas qu'il existe vraiment
bien sûr suivre pendant la semaine de
relâche plusieurs personnes voudront
voir nelly et simon mission ici dans
lequel tu fais car de la voix de simon
alors qu'est ce qui le branche dans un
genre dans ce genre de projet j'ai
l'impression cette année diana jones en
dessin animé et j'ai toujours rêvé de
participer à ce genre de film là
j'aurais voulu être une diana jones dans
la vie ça a été montré et bien là je
peux je peux le jouer par procuration
par la bande puis je fais la voie d'un
intellectuel qui intellectuels
universitaires
alors ma mère serait fier de mon pas
parce que je n'ai pas été à l'université
mais au moins 20 juin c'est la beauté
des acteurs c'est de jouer tout ce que
t'as pas réussi à être dans la vie on
trouvera la cinémathèque où il ya
quelques semaines on présentait le film
le matou sa cliente a longtemps entaché
d'amis qu'il est amour ça qu'est ce que
ça te fait de revoir les images de ce
film là encore aujourd'hui tout va bien
tu viens d'avoir 42 ans de se replonger
dans un moment de sa vie importants
comme ce que j'ai vécu dans le film à
tous ben ça vient nous chercher ça vient
nous rappeler une belle période
enfin pour moi c'est une belle période
de ma vie où je comptais d'éloigner de
moi votre bateau sinon je transforme les
moments où je me fais chicaner jeudi à
l'avenant regard gager gaudré là j'ai eu
de rire parce qu'ils me chicane je
trouvais ça drôle ou de ne pas chicaner
parce que je savais que c'était pas vrai
puis le réalisateur est qu'ils aient
reste sérieux et l'autre pas drôle
eustache can et je le sais mais c'est
drôle comme une chicane fait ça me
rappeler des bons moments
alors ça ça me souvenais au moins dix
matches où c'est le président de
revanche est pour mais non pas qu'il
prenne dans ses bras une coche dans la
couverture enroulée pas de siège de tout
ça n'existait pas ce moment le couche en
arrière sur la banque et de la voiture
et on s'en va sur le tournage puis je me
réveille tranquillement je tenterai de
me faire maquiller coiffer pour aller
faire une scène que j'avais appris de
trois jours avant c'est du grand plaisir
pour moi de tout au fil des hardtois
beaucoup parler de ta vie privée en
public un exemple sur internet tu as
annoncé que des nouvelles conjointes il
ya pas si longtemps que ça comment tu
trace la ligne justement
trop ta vie publique est ta vie privée
la vérité c'est que on peut pas la trace
est vraiment mais c'est pas un contrôle
qu'ont acquis évident parce qu'à partir
du moment où je réponds aux questions je
tendrais falla c'est ce qu'il ya des
entrevues qui peuvent découler de sow
puis le web végétal ma vie publique sans
nécessairement le dis pas que je le
disais pas mon challenge là dedans je
suis depuis le tout début mais j'ai pas
le désir nécessairement de parler de
mire ceux de mes amours de messine aimé
ça mais cet avis et andoni d'un bib et
en parle parce que sinon de quoi on
parle des dons mais c'est un mal
nécessaire parce que je pense que les
gens aiment ce canton l'acceptent on
accepte
moi je sais ce que je fais moi j'ai un
rapport amour-haine avec les réseaux
sociaux
[Applaudissements]
pour peu de voix représentant à la
télévision dans la télésérie rupture
puis dans ce schéma serpent ou tu le
gérant de bar de danseurs sur ma
question venir tout de suite
sylvain archambault creator la première
saison top entendu là-dessus
puis on n'a pas besoin de l'entente
n'ont plus ces propos rien je me suis
pas prononcé les choses arrivent puis
puis personnellement qu'est ce qu'on
peut ajouter à ce qui arrive déjà on y
qui a dit je me suis plu mais dont des
coupables ou jugé le matin et puis on
pense wall c'est un peu ça alors non
j'ai pas grand chose à rajouter
là-dessus en fait j'ai rien à jouer a
ajouté
c'est dommage parce que j'aurais des
choses à dire mais on peut pas les dire
parce que les choses sont mal
interprétés
et les choses ne sont jamais retenu dans
leur entièreté
pour moi les réseaux sociaux quand une
phrase a aucun d'une citation sort par
exemple si je me prononce en ce moment
une phrase qui est retenu et c'est comme
si tu es l'ensemble de ma pensée qui est
envoyé et là les gens en font ce qu'ils
veulent et là moi je peux plus dire à
fait ce que je voulais attention nuance
il ya plus de possibilité de faire ça
donc c'est trop délicat et c'est dommage
parce que ça empêche les gens de pouvoir
justement nuancé si je me prononce jeudi
noix ou jeudi blain et si je pense
grille je peux pas me prononcer je
termine là dessus guillaume étudiant du
théâtre cet été que tu produis
d'ailleurs soient montés sur scène
la télévision l'école de parachutisme
comment trouves-tu le temps de tout
faire sans même ben en fait quand on
entend parler de ce que je fais juste
une vie très occupés que j'ai
c'est des périodes
et comme disait ma mère disait moche
millionnaire de teint et c'est une belle
phrase qu'il faut retenir le teint est
beaucoup plus précieux et vous avez vous
beaucoup plus cher qu'on peut l'imaginer
et avoir des beaux projets c'est génial
c'est merveilleux c'est jeu des baux
problème
faucheux s'entasser certains pour
réussir à vivre à travers du son mais de
toute façon mon plus grand défi c'est
d'être le meilleur père est le meilleur
qu'on jouait possible ce sera toujours
ça ma pire en réussite même si je me
plais énormément dans le métier que
j'exerce guillaume lemay thivierge merci
infiniment c'est un véritable plaisir
brisé pour moi partager